WHOLE CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL STARTS TO
DO.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL
THESE THINGS YOU SAY IT'S GOING
TO DO.
I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU,
TUESDAY NIGHT WAS NOT GREAT FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THERE IS NOW A REPUBLICAN-ELECT
GOVERNOR IN VIRGINIA.
REPUBLICANS ALMOST PULLED OFF AN
UPSET IN NEW JERSEY.
YOU ARE A FORMER GOVERNOR.
WHAT LESSONS DO YOU TAKE AWAY
FROM TUESDAY?
>> THANK GOD THE DEMOCRATS IN
THE HOUSE GOT THIS MESSAGE LOUD
AND CLEAR, PASS THE BILL AND
PASS THE SECOND PART, TOO,
BECAUSE THESE CONTAIN THINGS
THAT EVERYDAY PEOPLE CARE ABOUT.
THE GOVERNOR OF MICHIGAN TODAY,
GRETCHEN WHITMER, RAN ON THE
PHRASE "FIX THE DAMNED ROADS."
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES,
FIXES THE DAMNED ROADS AND
BRIDGES.
IT GETS BROADBAND TO REAL
PEOPLE, THE SECOND PART INVESTS
IN CHILD CARE WHICH WE'RE THE
ONLY INDUSTRIALIZED NATION THAT
DOESN'T HELP FAMILIES WITH CHILD
CARE.
THESE ARE THE BASICS, BRINGING
DOWN THE COSTS OF LIVING FOR
REAL PEOPLE.
SO THAT YOU'RE NOT PAYING $500 A
YEAR TO FIX YOUR CAR BECAUSE YOU
RAN OVER A POTHOLE.
>> COST OF LIVING, GAS PRICES.
ACCORDING TO AAA, THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE OF GAS PRICES IS NOW
$3.42 A GALLON.
BANK OF AMERICA IS PREDICTING
CRUDE OIL PRICES COULD SOAR
ANOTHER 50% BY NEXT JUNE.
COULD THE AVERAGE GAS PRICE IN
AMERICA BE $4 A GALLON IN THE
UNITED STATES SOON?
>> WELL, WE CERTAINLY HOPE NOT.
AS I SAY, THE ENERGY INFORMATION
AGENCY IS GOING TO PUT OUT THEIR
FORECAST THIS WEEK.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALL OVER THIS,
OF COURSE, EVERY PRESIDENT IS
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
CONTROL THE PRICE OF GASOLINE
BECAUSE IT'S A GLOBAL MARKET.
HE CAN CALL UPON INCREASED
SUPPLY WHICH HE HAS DONE AND
OPEC IS UNFORTUNATELY
CONTROLLING THE AGENDA WITH
RESPECT TO OIL PRICES.
OPEC IS A CARTEL AND SUPPLIES
OVER 50% OF GAS LINE.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IT DO ABOUT OPEC?
>> HE WITH CALL UPON THEM TO
INCREASE SUPPLY AND THEY HAVE
CHOSEN NOT TO.
THAT INCREASES THE CHOKEHOLD TO
ACCESS AFFORDABLE FUEL AT THE
PUMP.
THE PRESIDENT IS LOOKING AT THE
TOOLS HE HAS.
>> STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE?
>> ONE OF THE TOOLS HE HAS AND
HE IS LOOKING AT THAT AND I
THINK WE'LL BE LOOKING AT THAT
FORECAST THAT'S COMING OUT ON
TUESDAY.
>> SHOULD AMERICANS, LIKELY BE A
COLD WINTER, MOST OF THEM ARE,
EXPECT TO PAY HIGHER PRICES FOR
HEATING THEIR HOMES?
>> YES.
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT WILL BE MORE EXPENSIVE THIS
YEAR THAN LAST YEAR.
WE ARE IN A SLIGHTLY BENEFICIAL
POSITION, CERTAINLY RELATIVE TO
EUROPE, BECAUSE THEIR CHOKEHOLD
OF NATURAL GAS IS SIGNIFICANT.
THEY'LL PAY FIVE TIMES HIGHER.
WE HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM IN
FUELS THAT THE SUPPLY CHAINS
HAVE, WHICH IS THAT THE OIL AND
GAS COMPANIES ARE NOT FLIPPING
THE SWITCH AS QUICKLY AS THE
DEMAND REQUIRES.
SO THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN FOCUSED ON BOTH THE
IMMEDIATE TERM AND THE
LONG-TERM.
LET US GET OFF OF THE VOLATILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH FOSSIL FUELS AND
ASSOCIATED WITH OTHERS WHO DON'T
HAVE OUR COUNTRY'S INTERESTS AT
HEART AND INVE